what are your thoughts on
budgeting having a personal budget
my thoughts are that you should have it
you definitely need to have a budget you
need to
know what you can afford and then not
afford and you have a plan and you stick
to the plan and that's how you get to it
that's what you should do um i i don't
have the discipline for that so i'd be
i'd be
working if i told you that i was that i
practiced those uh those best practices
do you rent uh or buy or when you're
you're where you live you rent or buy i
i've done both
um but i'm actually i just bought a
condo there's there's there's cost
benefit that both of those
uh it's not necessarily the end of the
world if you rent there's a lot of
good arguments towards renting and i've
leveraged those arguments but
right now the benefits of owning in my
particular situation in my particular
country far outweighed those
benefiting so i'm switching over to
ownership especially when you have kids
now you said when you're
when you're young and single it's
there's definitely advantages to renting
um thoughts on having debt
specifically consumer debt credit card
debt
car loans that kind of a thing the
interest rate what are your thoughts on
consumer debt yeah consumer i'm glad you
made that distinction because of
because that isn't necessarily bad uh
but consumer debt
obviously it's it's a bad thing it's
like a negative asset it just kind of
sucks
uh sucks your body out like this this
idea buy now pay later
buy it buy it over time or installments
there's times when that makes sense
uh but for the most part and it's
there's times where you make sense where
like i could pay for this right now
but i get six months you know interest
free on on this particular thing and
it's debt because you owe it but it's
interest free so it costs you whatever
you take that money and you can put it
into us whatever
interest generating account during those
six months so there are there are
examples where you can use
debt to your favor but if we're just
talking about i'm going to buy something
and the money is not in my bank account
i'm going to swipe this card and now
and i'm going to own this thing uh it's
it's a
it's a downward spiral and it feeds off
itself